[Musique]
eq soignant avec la terrière de casser
et aujourd'hui on est en train de faire
un véhicule qui a été accidenté et sur
lequel on a fait une expertise à
distance spécialisée dans la voiture
sans permis ce groupe a dû stopper son
activité commerciale dans les huit
concessions d'île de france en raison de
la crise sanitaire
seule la permanence atelier mécanique à
coignières a été conservé une offre
particulière pour le personnel soignant
a été mise en place fin mars
on a dû tout simplement qu'on allait
donc bien vite et bien évidemment ouvrir
l'activité aux voitures sans permis et
aux voitures traditionnelles parce qu'on
sait faire
les pièces détachées à prix coûtant la
main d'oeuvre avec une remise à 10%
si les véhicules ne pouvais pas rouler
on faisait le transport à prix coûtant
aussi huit salariés travaillent
habituellement sur ce site
aujourd'hui ils ne sont que trois en
activité
tous portent des combinaisons des
masques et des gants afin de respecter
les règles sanitaires
on a mis aussi en place plus de
protection au sein des véhicules des
clients d ou sur les sièges ou ce volant
ou ce levier de vitesse ou ce frein à
main mise à disposition des clés dans le
véhicule zéro contact avec le client
tous les types de règlement chèque
espèces ou carte bancaire sont acceptés
et on désinfecte bien évidemment aussi
le tpe si le confinement se poursuit
jusqu'à fin avril ce dirigeant a estimé
une perte de 6 cents mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires pour son groupe
ils continuent malgré tout à proposer
cette offre de solidarité aux personnels
soignants mais aussi au personnel de la
grande distribution